طفله بعمر ثلاث سنوات اختفت من امام منزل
ذويها لعده ايام ثم عثر على جثتها مشوهه
ومرميه قرب مكب للنفايات تم القاء القبض
على القاتل وظهر يروي اعترافاته على شاشه
التلفاز لتكشف لاحقا حقائق صادمه حول
ملابسات مقتل الطفله
الاسم الطفله جوا اسطنبولي المكان حمس
المتهم مجهول
في الثامنه من شهر اغسطس عام 2022 ضجت
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بنبا اختفاء طفله
تدعى جوا اسطنبولي وتبلغ من العمر ثلاث
سنوات من امام منزلها في حي المهاجرين
بحمص السوريه لم يستغرق البحث عنها سوى
ايام قليله ثم عثر على جثتها مرميه في مكب
للنفايات قرب حمص
كانت الجثه مشوهه لدرجه ان والدتها تعرفت
عليها من خلال ملابسها فقط
تقرير الطب الشرعي كشف ان سبب وفاه الطفله
كان النزف الشديد الناجم عن ضرب الراس
باله حاده وبعد موجه واسعه من الغضب عمه
الشارع السوري الذي طالب بالعثور على
القاتل اعلنت اجهزه الامن في النظام
السوري القبض على شخص يدعى مدينه الاحمد
وقالت انه اعترف بجريمته بعد التحقيق معه
مؤكده انه يعاني من اضطرابات النفسيه ثم
ظهر القاتل يروي اعترافاته على شاشه
التلفاز شفت في اربع بنات ما يلعبوا
بالطابه والعالم
اجتني فكره ان نجيب وحده من البنات لعندي
على البيت
نزلت على الشارع
رحت لعند البنت
مسكتها وجبتها لعندي على المدخل
حطيت اذاعه امه
وطلعت انا عندي عشقه
اغتصبت للبنت ورجعت كمان خلقت
لحتى عرفت انه خلص يعني طلعت انفاسه
اعترافات المتهم اثارت الربا والشك لدى
السوريين خصوصا انها تناقضت مع تقرير
الطبيب الشرعي الذي اكد وفاتها نتيجه
تعرضها للضرب باله حاده على الراس كما انه
لم يشير بتاتا الى تعرضها للاغتصاب وفيما
اتهم ناشطون السلطات بتلفيق تلك
الاعترافات وانتزاعها من المتهم المزعوم
الذي ترددت انباء عن وفاته لاحقا في احد
المستشفيات جاءت الصاعقه عن الملابسات
الحقيقيه لجريمه مقتل جواب المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان كشف ان والد الطفل المدعو
طارق اسطنبولي وهو عنصر بامن الفرقه
الرابعه التابعه لماهر الاسد كان على خلاف
حول شحنه مواد مخدره مع تاجر مخدرات يعمل
لصالح ميليشيا حزب الله اللبنانيه فعمد
الاخير الى تهديده لاعاده شحنه المخدرات
وحين لم ينفع التهديد ارسل احد عناصره
لخطف الصغيره ثم قتلها امام اعين والدها
الذي كان يشاهده صغيرته تلفظ انفاسها
الاخيره عبر مكالمه بالصوت والصوره
الم
دى
وكان مع والدها بمكالمه بالصوت والصوره
وهو يقوم بقتلها بدم بارد
بصرف النظر عن ظروف مقتل جوى تبقى الحقيقه
الصادمه ان طفله بعمر ثلاث سنوات كان
مصيرها القتل بتلك الطريقه البشعه